hey 42 here at some point in human
history we realize that if we left the
cave door unlocked someone might come
along and steal our collection of
bearskins and our favorite rock so what
was the solution we couldn't be
everywhere at once so perhaps we needed
a group of people to watch our cave
prevent Rock theft and make sure no one
rode a mammoth too quickly for a
pedestrian zone unfortunately although
rock theft did decline this new cave
watching group became suspiciously
well-dressed and were getting all of the
best bits of antelope at the nightly
barbecue police corruption has been an
issue throughout the ages because as the
Roman poet Juvenal once wrote who
watches the Watchmen good policing
undoubtedly makes our lives better and
easier but it's a difficult balancing
act to get it right so whether it's
making money on the side avoiding blame
for suspicious wrongdoings or a genuine
belief that the end really does justify
the means
today we look at four massive police
cover-ups from around the world
Los Angeles has a lot of gangs and if it
wasn't for all the drugs violence and
murder the amount of diversity on show
would almost make you proud there's two
Bloods the Crips the watching and other
triads the unimaginative Lee named white
power group Nazi lowriders ms-13 and
plenty of other Latino gangs there's
also the terrifying Los Angeles war
gamers whose Army is dark hell's and
endless grain resource cards have
terrorized a board gaming community for
years you can take their lives but no
one will ever take their virginity's to
tackle this smorgasbord of criminal
subgroups the LAPD assigned each
division an anti-gang team called
community resources against street
hoodlums or crash which began in 1979
but when Officer Kevin gains of the
rampart division was shot by an
undercover police officer in 1997 the
subsequent investigation revealed the
police unit that didn't just have one or
two bad apples the whole barrel was
rotten the rampart scandal revealed that
the rampart crash team had planted false
evidence performed unprovoked shootings
and beatings stolen and dealt narcotics
lied in court committed bank robbery and
more in trying to give gang members a
lengthy rap sheets they had actually
written their own a number of officers
moonlighted our security for their
hip-hop record label death row records
which had links to the blood skunk it's
possible that some of these officers
were even involved in the execution of
Biggie Smalls the LAPD had a real mess
to clean up and eventually paid out of
125 million dollars in civil lawsuits
they also disciplined around 25 officers
and a handful went to jail including
Rafael Perez who snitched on all the
other officers in exchange for a reduced
sentence on 15th of April 1989 the worst
disaster in British sporting history
happened at Hillsborough football
stadium in Sheffield when 96 Liverpool
fans were crushed to death jongen FH
semi-final game nowadays every team in
the top two leagues must have an
all-seater stadium largely in reaction
to this tragedy on the day two pens with
Liverpool fans were already very full
but there were still lots of fans
outside the turnstiles when the game was
close to kickoff these fans were all
directed into the overcrowded pens and
the ensuing jam of people crushed
everyone so tightly that many suffocated
initially the fans were blamed the Sun
newspaper owned by Australian media
vampire Rupert Murdoch printed a front
page headlines the truth that claimed
that Liverpool fans had pickpocketed the
victims urinated on police and even
prevented them from giving CPR to the
injured all of these were proved to be
completely false and the Sun newspaper
is still boycotted across the city of
Liverpool to this day but it wasn't just
a son who were wronged the police led by
David duckenfield on the day spent
decades pushing the blame onto drunken
Liverpool fans and fans without tickets
duckenfield claimed that the fans forced
their way in for a large exit gate when
in fact he himself had ordered it to be
opened to relieve the bottleneck that
with building up outside ignoring the
fatal crush happening inside the gate in
2012 an independent report was finally
published bringing the truth to life and
in August this year an investigation
began into duckenfield revealing that
the police forces utter disregard for
people's safety and that tragic day when
96 innocent spectators were crushed to
death because of negligence now we head
to the heart of the caucuses the
beautiful country of Georgia after the
collapse of the Soviet Union Georgia was
in a pretty bad state it may have had
hundreds of stunning mountains a rich
history of winemaking and the national
food called khachapuri which is a bread
boat filled with cheese and topped with
a fried egg but sadly in this second
twisted world that is simply not enough
large gangs controlled much of the
but that all changed when mikhail
saakashvili became the president in
january 2004 following the nonviolent
revolution of roses in November 2003 he
promised to end police corruption and
gang control and he did by scrapping the
entire police force and starting again
from scratch a fellow revolutionary bat
acutally explained the reason for this
radical overhaul when he compared
tackling corruption to quote-unquote
building a ship in the middle of the sea
while sailing whilst also learning how
to sail and while you have somebody
attacking and trying to sink your ship
excellent point you can see why they got
the boat
I mean vote the trouble was his new
force were a little too motivated and
before too long
corruption was completely gone because
they basically locked everyone up ending
up with their highest per-capita prison
population in Europe in March 2006
police claims to have prevented a riot
by the inmates in Tbilisi prison
organized by gang leaders but they did
it by preventing seven inmates from
continuing to live as well as injuring
17 there was also massive Eiland
telephone tapping and torture now there
are a number of big British secret such
as why do we eat so much Marmite and why
do so many English people play all of
America's superheroes and films but the
story of Mao Mao was and is one of the
closest guarded secrets where the
actions of the colonial police and
military in Kenya were mostly suppressed
for over 50 years in the early 1950s the
native Kenyan population particularly
the Kikuyu people thought that the
British might relax their occupation a
little especially after the Kenyans had
fought for them in World War two
obviously they had never been overly
delighted at being colonized in the
first place people are often not as
grateful as you'd think
when you move into their house and eat
all their food even if you do have an
excellent collection of mustaches a
rebel group called the Mau Mau appeared
killing around 200 euro
and colonial sympathizers the Brits use
propaganda to paint the Malmo as evil
boogeyman framing their activity as part
of a civil war among the Kikuyu in order
to protect loyal Kikuyu and control
rebels they moved over 1 million Kenyans
into village camps that were effectively
giant ghoul acts with living conditions
dependent on how loyal a believes each
person to be they used white settlers to
control the camps and there was mass
scale torture and executions
it's shocking enough on its own but when
you consider that this was less than a
decade after the horrors of Nazi Germany
the hypocrisy was probably the main
reason why the stories and documents
were buried it's forced that over 20,000
Kenyans died and some 5000 more were
tortured Barack Obama's grandfather
Hussein and y'know Obama had pins forced
into his fingernails and his testicles
squeezed between rods whilst two other
men with him were castrated you see the
UK in the u.s. really do have a special
relationship we go way back it wasn't
until 2011 that's a landmark court case
of Kenyan victims against the British
government brought much of the evidence
to light it turned out that many
documents had been kept in a government
building in hands lope Park probably
brought back by Colonials who disagreed
with what had happened and wanted it on
record that they had complained so it
just goes to show you never can trust
the men in blue and remember you always
have a voice so if you're being
oppressed speak up for yourself unless
the men in blue are pointing guns in
your face then you should probably shut
the hell up thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2 kowloon
walled city was home to over 33,000
people all comes into a measly six acres
but there's a map equally as despicable
as adult Hitler yet very few people even
know of his existence